let's cut to the chase Abbi your
teaching methods can be pretty
questionable yelling throwing things
pointing your finger in people's faces
these are all things you've mastered
along the way but we can't deny that
when it comes to winning titles the
aldc's reputation is downright stellar
so you've got to be doing something
right but would it really be so bad to
try and be a little nicer to your
students this was your sister we would
be let's face it guys Abby Lee Miller is
the best in the business but that
doesn't make her any easier to work with
we've got some of Abby's finest moments
lined up for you stay tuned as we reveal
the ten times Abby went too far on Dance
Moms
rejected Abby Lee Miller is the clap
back master and she doesn't let anyone
forget it in season 5 episode 25 a be
completely snubs Jojo Kalani and Nia in
front of their very own mothers when the
girls come close to Abby to give her a
hug she welcomes Maddie Mackenzie and
Kendall with open arms but says when the
other girls approached her Abby's petty
behavior leads to her and Kira getting
into a huge fight
Abby totally took things too far leave
the children out of it sneak and a liar
Abby speaks her mind that's just the way
she is love it or hate it she's the best
in the business but if you want to work
with her you better make the ALDC a top
priority Abby took things too far when
she put Christi on blast for letting
Chloe go on a school field trip turns
out missing a single evening is
unacceptable Abby took things a step
further by telling Christi that she was
a sneak and a liar and that she was
raising her kid to be the same exact
thing
every week we put the trash out Abby Lee
Miller isn't someone you want to mess
with but that never stopped minister
dawn from trying
Abby is notorious for taking things too
far in season 1 episode 1 she kicks
Regan out of a crow class for
disrespecting the dress code and when
her mother dawn check finds out she
confronts Abby right away but instead of
dealing with Dawn's complaints Abby
kicks her and her daughter out of the
studio but before she does so she tells
dawn out that must've hurt she deserves
nothing in season 5 episode 7 Jojo gets
ranked in this place during pyramid and
her mother jessalyn is quick to come to
her defense just a Lynne tells Abby that
Jojo did a good job and deserves praise
and Abby says that if Jojo is so good
she doesn't need to be a part of her
Dance Company
when jessalyn says that Jojo deserves to
be there Abby yells out Abby then goes
off on a rampage bringing Jojo to tears
in no time learn some manners Abby's
always been quick to put Jojo in her
place whenever she speaks out of line
and this time Abby totally lost her cool
Abby took things a little too far by
schooling Jojo in front of her mother
and friends but in Abby's defense she
was just trying to teach her some
manners till she learns to say excuse me
when two adults are speaking and we're
sure that's one lesson she'll never
forget not coming home putting people on
speakerphone is never a good idea an
Abby Lee Miller can attest to that Abby
took things way too far when she
insulted Brooke and Paige in front of
everyone at the ALDC in season three
Melissa called Abby to find out where
she was only to find out that Abby was
in Orlando when Melissa asked Abby when
she would be coming home she replied
ding-dong it's no secret that Abby
thought that Paige and Brooke Hyland
weren't cut out for the world of
competitive dance in her opinions they
didn't catch on quick and put a damper
on her reputation
Abby's comments were hurtful and
damaging and part of the reason why the
Hyland's chose to leave the Dance Moms
behind in this scene we see a be calling
Paige a ding-dong for getting her steps
wrong now that's some serious verbal
abuse poor Paige Satan destroys it in
season 4 episode 9 Abby gives Chloe a
compliment for the first time in a long
time but when Abby discusses her
attendance record Christy claps back she
says that Chloe is always in the studio
and Abby says that maybe Chloe's
sneaking out the back door to meet boys
this comment was totally uncalled for
and if that wasn't bad enough
Abby goes on to call Christy Satan nice
one Abby Abby gets it wrong in season 6
episode 2 Abby takes her rage out on
poor little Mackenzie first Abby
ridicules Kenzie for not learning her
dance fast enough and compares her to
Maddie this was her sister we would be
halfway finished with the number she
then gets mad at can see for not
remembering the name of her solo when in
reality it's Abby who gets it wrong I
just want to sit on the couch Abby
called Kenzie a few bad names and sends
her off crying I thought the witch would
melt in season 3 episode 7 Cathy from
the candy apples Dance Center enters the
ALDC dressing room looking for a fight
and boy does she get one
Abby loses her cool and throws water on
Cathy and soon after she says
no Abby took things a step too far by
throwing water on Cathy but the which
sort of deserved it Abby Lee Miller is
notorious for taking things too far and
these are some of her worst moments on
the set of Dance Moms how do you guys
feel about Abby's personality sound off
in the comments section below for more
videos about your favorite TV shows and
movies subscribe to the things and be
sure to give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll catch you next
time
[Music]